alright I hope that went well we will
now talk about the most flexible query
mechanism and data store query by kind
filter by property let's say you would
like to query for all conferences that
are in a particular City for example
Halloween and with a specific topic like
moviemaking and then sort the matching
entries by conference name for example
if we were to write this out it could
look like this retrieve all conferences
that are in the city Halloween and has
moviemaking in the topic sort the result
by name this is an example of query by
kind filter by property since we are
using property values in the search and
the sort let's look at this a little bit
closer we want to have an exact match
for the city since we are only
interested in conferences in Halloween
this is called an equality filter then
we want to further restrict the query so
that only entities which has moviemaking
in the topic are displayed this is
called a member of filter we are
combining these with the end operator
meaning that both of these conditions
must be true and finally we are sorting
the result by name let's look at filters
and how you can use them to construct a
query in more detail the first filter is
the Equality filter that we used for
City in our example then we have the
member of filter which has the same
symbol as the Equality filter this
filter we use to sort by topic then we
have a set of inequality filters not
equal to less than less than or equal to
greater than greater than or equal to
and all of these can be combined using
the boolean operators and and/or that's
enough theory to get started so now it's
time for you to add query by kind filter
by property to come from central